ryser winch
combien tomlinson je vais maintenant
vous présenter serge gainsbourg qui pour
vous c'est mieux en smoking voilà j'ai
gagné mon pari
j'ai gagné mon pari voilà whitney
houston serge gainsbourg gainsbarre pour
les intimes
voilà asseyez-vous serge dites lui que
vous l'avez trouvée sublime voilà serge
gainsbourg auriez-vous de ma demande
comment allez-vous baril va bien rien
bercy est un super si ça marche de
marché deux seulement de ces joueurs est
venus ici aujourd'hui 105 me jean yole
hiis ezio a dit que vous êtes très joli
c'est son goût du dinar you are not
gagnent à note cours bat kovacevic au
dolce rien ay cède à world of soccer
oui alors je vais vous traduire non non
non non non loris et johan cruijff
il dit que vous êtes très joli non non
non non non c'est non il a dit ça mais
ça lui arrive devant rien je peux pas
vous traduire ce qu'il a dit il a dit
j'aimerais bien vous auriez wapler pas
du tout j'ai dit jean réduire apaisé il
mais il a dit il a dit tendre enfance y
non non et non
il est normal vous imaginez quand il est
sous ce nom vous inquiétez pas huit mais
non illégal et il est pas vraiment c'est
aussi en est anormal
oui mais on va maintenant super bien sûr
qu'elle est super presse à moscou et
dans la ville rebelle présent tu tes
excuses à 6,6 fun fly voilà il apologize
il s'excuse il s'excuse pas c'est un
grand enfant
il aura pas de cigarettes cela dit ben
alors bon qui m'a convaincu les 10 on
retrouve eddy mitchell d'accord les jeux
si oui oui d'accord jeudi aux fraises à
sévir et ça va peut-être les villes de
continuer de rêver 6 1 voilà qu'est ce
qui m'a fait d'inviter gainsbourg encore
tiens with le prototype donné par
dutronc le voilà en tout cas whitney
houston
elle est pas prête d'oublier champs
elysées je peux vous dire venir non non
ça va jouer ici sur le bretteur
zigzaguant et finit à donne sur situer
dans notre sublime sublime sublime c'est
mieux que superbe
qu'est ce que je vais bien maintenant ah
bah oui je vais eddy mitchell et puis
elle élimine
peur le voile se lève enfin sur l'invité
mystère nuit tard gueulard couche-tard
pinard pétards les auteurs je crois que
les gens tôt reconnu en garde à vue
mystère
je crains pendant l'émission nombreux
chinois si tu penses interpellé c'est
pas qu'on me reconnaisse et qu'on se dit
ouh là là tu as eu sept sont rougis
l'ouest dit non à mon avis qu'ils
dépensent en nombre chez us à soyaux
hasard
oh
les gens je dis ce que tu es le robert
mitchum français ah oui oui suivant oui
dans les bistrots dubaï la bourse en
heure c'est j'ai passé tellement vite
chômé
alors évidemment par rapport à beaucoup
d'autres jacques tient jeudi impression
que ça aux gens ouais ils ont pas vu les
autres alors regardons les siens j'ai vu
un film là de toi qui l'a passé à
télévision le 1er octobre qui s'appelle
les sirènes de minuit on est venu c'est
un très très très très grand film pour
moi
finement mais qui est grand parce qu'il
est parce qu et du rouge dedans je fais
du rouge devant parce que elle parce que
le moteur le mobile c'est du racine pour
moi le mobile c'est l'amour et mécanique
implacable une fois que c'est comment ça
va oui même si comme si c'est quand j'ai
racisme propre emploi et non mais c'est
comme une tragédie est très bien composé
et le drame du cinéma français c'est
qu'on s'attend à trouver une tragédienne
je veux dire je vais travailler parce
qu'on se souvienne l'école mais là le
lyrisme iyed du notation une version
moderne dans l'image même chanson plus
tout le monde voit tous les jours dans
sa vie non c'est m on dira qu'on lui
pour résumer ces ballons travailler avec
quelqu'un qui pour moi est un des
meilleurs mais pour moi philippe
lefebvre ont le vrai je parle m'a donné
une leçon et ces temps derniers rôles
d'alcoolo pareil c'est à dire à l'eau
mélangée tournée j'ai trouvé le tout
venant j'ai trouvé un fournisseur qui
m'a expliqué comment il fallait faire
pour avoir un semblant par exemple
offert une scène des brouettes ne doit
pas pas le problème n'est pas là
problème il est drôle c'est comme si le
la gâchette écoles laissent penser
qu'une bouchée pour est un tueur mais
peu d'ail au de vous sauver mais bouna
pour être moins bon voilà c'est comme si
on envoyait
justement parlez vous avez l'impression
qu'il avoue chantier en plein dedans
pourquoi parce qu'ils jouent bien je
fais bien les alcools
moi j'ai un seul problème c'est que je
suis meilleur en course le problème
c'est que je joue mieux que les autres
alors qu'ils la couleur verte française
on essaye de faire l'alcool au travail
et sept longues années de pratique
pour y faire un centre parce que tout à
l'heure
elle m'a dit j'ai peur je suis dans tous
les états je vais vous expliquer comment
va se passer l'émission et je le dis
compte sur ma porte s'apaiser te calmer
et une attitude pour te calmes et voilà
maintenant si tu comptes sur le match
jusqu'au bout avec moi à quoi alors j'ai
pas dit j'ai pas dû à ces les crues
tranquille enjoy
alors je suis là pour te protéger la
tombe bien parce qu'un atout de ces
caméras servent là ta peau parce que ses
téléspectateurs tu te désire tord et à
travers
hajek ya quand même qu'il ya quand même
des gens je serai là oui tu n'as rien à
craindre
ah si il ya quand même des gens qui vous
reprochent à la prof d'ailleurs il ya
des gens qui me disent c'est vrai que
cela il en fait beaucoup
alors
le roi c'est michel aumont a été
formidable et sa fille c'est vous ouais
et alors qu'est ce que c'est que cette
jeune femme elle et elle est naïve et
nous en parlerons de tout ça tout à
l'heure dans une princesse très
distinguée princesse c'est du passé et
je t'emmerde
cette fois c'est voir arriver dans sa
vie un playboy alors qu'est ce que c'est
c'est eh oui c'est un playboy ces
conditions là c'est pas difficile c'est
de gaulle qui à la suite d'un pari va
avoir du pain comme j'ai dit
précédemment
comme des choses avec le bouquet alors
écoutez moi je lançais confettis chaque
fois je sais ce play-boy intervient donc
dans l'existence de ce principe dans
cette cour et ils vont en arriver à as
épousé nous allons regarder la
répétition du mariage car tous doit se
passer dans la convention bien établie
il n'ya pas l'hiver patrick aussi mais
moi je te dirai pas daniel mais ça fait
rien n'est ce pas un peu parlé l'éternel
je disais il ya deux choses très vite
mais la dame très vite chuté j'ai
conscience avait deux choses vous savez
l'argent et le sexe ou puisque on est
entre nous lors elle que quoi c'était m
donc je me suis rebellé contre la femme
est alors catherine paysan
deuxième constatation il ya 90% de
compte 10% deux frères les frères mais
chez les femmes c'est gratiné j'ai
rencontré des esprits sous payant chez
les femmes mais 1% lien ramassis de
kaunas je ne te dis que ça c'est comme
dire des choses qu'on peut vous aussi
vous voulez mais moi je ne sois pas
tellement bouleversée nous passions pour
dt glace parce que de temps en temps que
tel nous continuons bien trop au hockey
ciao
au revoir
ok mais finalement il n'y a pas
tellement la bouteille star américaine
voulait pas non mais là monsieur
monsieur
ces mêmes sources il fallait mettre un
format gif animés de loupe
il a porté ses bouteilles l'avions testé
boutin portsmouth était resté la
télévision qui l'ignorent il a porté
lui-même ses bouteilles je vais pas vous
pour apporter son manger moi au fond bon
soyons tolérants vous avez cette vision
des femmes c'est votre droit
d'autres peuvent avoir une autre vision
de la part de change ne voyez plus
m'arrêter façon c'est différent j'étais
moi je me suis toujours certes inégale
des hommes mais je pense qu'il faut pas
confondre d'égalité et d'identité